as many of you know there was a terrible
tragedy in France today 12 people were
killed because a satirical newspaper
made jokes that some group found
offensive now obviously everyone here
all of us are accustomed to bad news
from around the world but this story
really hits home for anyone who day in
and day out mocks political social and
religious figures in this country we
just take it for granted that it's our
right to poke fun at the untouchable or
the sacred but today's tragedy in Paris
reminds us very viscerally that it's a
right some people are inexplicably
forced to die for so it is very
important tonight that I expressed that
everybody who works at our comedy show
and believe it or not this is a comedy
show that's what we're trying to do here
all of us are terribly sad for the
families of those victims for the people
of France and for anyone in the world
tonight who now has to think twice
before making a joke it's not the way
it's supposed to be so we'll move on now
do a show do a great show